one of my most successful posts in the
history of my 15-year content career was
if you live for the weekends your [__]
is broken why do you hate Fridays so
much because I hate people that live
their lives for the weekend and I know
this because school was a disaster for
me and when I tell you I should have
been a weatherman Howie when I tell you
that when there was a potential snow day
I turned into literally a scientist I
knew everything I probably had a poster
of the Doppler radar in my high school
like I disliked school so much that I
would live for Friday at 3:00 p.m. and
that was fine and I understood that and
then somewhere in my 30s when this all
started happening I was like wait a
minute because then I went into my happy
Zone a grownup and lived I was like wait
a minute this is how most people live
their life this is not sustainable I
knew I was getting out at some point
this is what people are doing for 50
years and that got me passionate and
that's why I talk about what I talk
about attention is the number one asset